i think people are incredibly naive to
what i'm up to
so the i think the best buy
in all of v friends were the access
tokens
[Music]
if this is it i'm pumped this is why
blockchain's profound
this is the jammer here so i want to
give you guys as much info as i can this
is why you bought a hangout it's a big
[ __ ] fish i think a lot of people
misunderstand how valuable access is you
[ __ ] that was nasty
i really do believe when you say you're
just getting started like 100
you do not love losing you
i lost lose
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
heading up to uh milo's right now here
with may who i adore we're at milos in
hudson yards about to do the dinner gear
session which was one of the access
tokens in uh series one friend so
let's go see how this combo goes
i might be the most ambitious and
content person ever
it's super rare
it's why i'm weird it's why i pop it's
why i'm different you're talking about
massive contradictions i am
if this is it i'm pumped
yet i want to be number one of all time
i don't want a contradiction at all it's
fun it's just i enjoy it for the fun i
enjoy the complexity of trying
[Music]
one two touches
all right just getting out of the dinner
here with the boys
we're kind of getting back super excited
about the v friends access tokens
really looking forward to tomorrow big
day the series two starts
we've got the video games and the bubble
hockey i'll take that back drock i love
you see you later
[Music]
instagram what's good i'm live no we're
not oh we're super live
it's a lovely lady came she wanted to
play some uno
actually you know what i'm gonna let
people show up to the live i'm just
gonna sip my
really yeah i'm gonna just sip my coffee
here
be friends uno was played we played for
an hour played three games
why don't you tell the fans at home how
many you won
in three games
zero
zero victories for the visiting team
three and oh baby
such a pleasure nice to meet you
yes sir have you been practicing yeah i
know i'm [ __ ]
you played as a kid i did mom and i
played when we first came to america a
lot
uh and i have really fond memories of it
[Music]
when i first started working with my dad
it was a big transition period because
they were still coming from dvds and
like our industries in a time
yeah a lot of niche industries
get stuck that's where the opportunity
is there was no liquor store i talk a
lot about being early
my direct 10 competitors didn't build a
website for two full years you know how
much of an advantage that was yeah it's
crazy hey bill i'm in the mood for a
switcher
i hit the function hit the roads
i hit the staging nintendo time nintendo
damn it's in an xbox controller no all
right let's start with ice hockey
this is the jam right here
did your dad support your ideas like all
the way through the business or more
just later
pretty early on i was putting winds on
the board okay yeah from day one even at
14. he was like sell this wine and like
at lunchtime he'd be gone and be like
what the [ __ ] so like right away i kind
of got a lot of clout with him
yes my dad definitely my dad definitely
gave me
the room but what i love about that it
was earned because my dad
wouldn't have done that if i was a
schlemiel
they wanna knock me down but somehow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i need bigger pugs
[Music]
i won like nine out of ten bubba hockey
games you feel like that was right maybe
seven that didn't quite get the shutout
yeah
and we enjoyed the games but now to go
to a climb
[Music]
somehow i meeting stay up
[Music]
[Music]
i finally figured out what i'm going to
do i think i'm going to make like one of
the best pfp projects ever
i know that sounds kind of audacious but
it's the right way to think if you don't
think it for
yourself who the [ __ ] gonna think it
yeah you're right but i'm more like
practical you know what i mean so well
i'm uncomfortably practical yeah and i
always think i'm gonna build the best
yeah i hope that's like i don't think i
think too many people think that's a
contradiction i actually think it's the
punchline really i do i think people
struggle with things that seemingly on
paper seem opposite when in reality it's
the thing meaning to your point going
out and saying i'm going to build a
business that sounds outlandish yeah the
reality is
99 of people in the world that have ever
said things like that don't mean it and
it's a cover-up for their insecurity but
everybody who's ever done it also
thought it yeah like tom brady really
did go i mean i hate this keep using it
it pisses me off
but i know the stories and you have to
use the stories you know he really got
drafted in the sixth round he really in
the first practice went up to the owner
of the team and said this is gonna be
the best decision in your life that
really happened yeah it's a michigan
difference
but you know to me to me that's real
real stuff so i when i hear it
as an optimist i'm like
yeah okay
[Music]
vlog just did uh the brunch bears so the
whole fun thing to show the utility
nature of nfps i think a lot of people
misunderstand how valuable access is
and
it was important for me with be friends
to create an access level not just the
conference not just building out the ip
from a collectible standpoint so it's
kind of fun living the access life
[Music]
all right everybody love you okay what
do we got for me
[Music]
can i do a rant video
my friends i am running around this
world getting dm'd 24 7 running into
people in the street dabbing it up 24 7
in meetings one-on-ones groups keynotes
dm private email it's all the same game
everyone's trying to figure out how to
be [ __ ] happy and they think it's the
bag cash the wallet they think it's the
bag they think it's stuff
sneakers and [ __ ] they think it's stuff
they think it's a relationship a
validation like a blue [ __ ] check
mark they think it's all this outside
[ __ ] new york times bestseller million
followers ceo
it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] the only way
you can get happy which is what you're
all asking for
is to go [ __ ] inside with yourself
outside validation is a zero-sum game
people are gonna boo for you if they're
in a bad [ __ ] place people gonna
cheer for you if they're in a good
[ __ ] place that has nothing to
[ __ ] do with you and your process to
get yourself happy you wanna get happy
start talking to yourself
simplify [ __ ] make it about you yourself
not your parents not your plus one not
the [ __ ] world you with yourself by
yourself for you simplify that [ __ ] get
happy love yourself love your [ __ ]
self everybody else sucks too everybody
else is good at other stuff too just
love your [ __ ] self
[Music]
this is why the blockchain's profound i
could in nine years say okay if you have
one of each of the three b-con tickets
from that original thing
go here burn them do this happens and
this happened that's fun yeah it's game
play in perpetuity yeah i don't know who
has my wine i don't know who has my
sneakers but i'll always know
or can always check who owns a b friend
yeah and i can do things
it's cool yeah it's really game-changing
it's game-changing
that's why i like my gos that's why i
branded them because i think about like
watching the providence of where they
end up and they're like do i want to do
things with that like it's really just
fun forgot mine yeah yeah i bought it
directly yeah i know i just don't you
know that's what's also cool you don't
have to pay attention where they go no
of course you think you're [ __ ] down
anytime you look yeah yeah that's really
cool the blockchain's amazing like
[ __ ] amazing yeah like fun
[Music]
i'm in the midst of dropping series 2
but we're doing bowling boa a bunch of
people bowling i'm really excited about
it and so
i'm going to pull my ass off i'm not as
confident i'm a i'm an 80 to 120 bowler
[ __ ]
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i know i've been dominating
the games don't expect too much for me
here but i'll do what i can
[Music]
but i invested in twitter in 2007 by
2011 people were like oh
you did a good job four years ago
and then it was like and it wasn't like
a really great win until like
eight years later
99.9 of the world doesn't know about be
friends today and in 15 years like 25
will for sure
in that delta is like [ __ ] insanity
people are bad at that everything's so
condensed by the hour by the second
by the moment
nobody even knows what other teas are
yet
[Music]
i got very lucky i don't know if i would
have known my dad if i didn't
go into the family business like it's
almost hard for me to remember but like
my dad a very challenging childhood lost
his dad at 15 never saw him and his mom
who i knew very well
was a beacon of negativity you know my
dad
in a lot of ways got dramatically more
positive once i came into his life
like i've been having kind of memories
of it like he progressed a lot
you know in the 15 years i was with him
every day kind of thing so i'm very
empathetic to it my mom is such a
positive energy so i've seen both
and i was very close to my parents so i
got a real view of it so i'm very i feel
like i'm always able to resonate with
people because i've got
real [ __ ] experience on both sides of
the equation
[Music]
i'm sorry i hurt my back
no need to apologize it's my birthday
happy birthday
[Music]
that's awesome happy birthday
thank you
[Music]
sorry i'm just being in an awkward
position i'm rolling my ass
[Music]
would you remind us about the vision
like what is viking what does it mean to
you that this is happening the deepaks
the spike lees the pharrells me included
maybe me most of all included
all of that
is
seven percent of the vision 93 of the
vision is
summer camp
that's why it's three years i have what
people don't know about the ida crew
iraq eric and glenn to the guys that are
you know pop up and like some of this
stuff very limited content but people
know both got kicked out of school in
the first semester i went to school with
them for 12 weeks i'm still talking to
them 28 years later by the way back to
my point it all happened the first
weekend all of it i knew that discord
would build a community i can't even
imagine the excitement that people are
feeling right now to meet each other in
real life
yeah family reunion vibes 100
wait to the third day of actually
hanging out for three straight days now
you're fully
fully in family mode
what the [ __ ] do you think the con 2023
looks like
i think the relationship graph with each
other be friends with me friends is
gonna be profound i think people are
going to find the love of their life
being dead [ __ ] serious i think
people are going to find their business
partner of the future i think people are
going to find creativity trading
partners i believe we're an actual
community in a sea of non-communities
and i think it's going to be
unbelievable
[Music]
please let's make sure we protect people
that have won for the first time during
this era there's a lot of people running
around their friend circles right now
with a little bit of like a haha told
you you were stupid you should have
listened to me and bought a board ape
their self-identity their self-worth is
tied into the fact that they played the
nft market properly in the last year
when
when they lose
because they're gambling and they
haven't fully seen it they'll be a big
percentage of that some will sell that
but when that person that i just
described loses they're gonna have a
very difficult time facing their friends
and family because they've been gloating
when there's a market correction and
they lose they're going to be in a very
bad emotional state and i don't want to
lose any of our community to darkness
depression unhappiness or worse the
ultimate crime and this has all the
elements of that the reason i'm bringing
this up is i hope we start talking about
things like hey if you're winning in
nfts don't make fun of your non-nft
winning friends build them up and teach
them what's good bad and indifferent
because i see a ton of youthful energy
misplaying it and i've seen this in wall
street i've seen this in web one i've
seen this on web2 the amount of money
that's about to be lost over the next
three years is profound their self-worth
is gonna go down with it and when your
self-worth goes away you become
incredibly vulnerable to isolationism so
let's be more thoughtful in this space
there's incredible stuff going on it's
amazing but there's a lot of money
integrated into this and with money
comes a lot of danger we need thoughtful
combos in the space and that's why i
wanted to give that spiel right now
thank you everyone love all of you
[Music]
yeah i have so many og friends like from
the wine world and like 70 80 90 year
olds gary can i speak to you for 15
minutes and you know they're the ogs
that i grew up with so i'm like i got
you you know johnny and then they spend
the entire 13 minutes [ __ ] on crypto
and i love it because i understand the
essence of it but i always end the same
way i'm like kind of take the punches
and then i'm like johnny how much cash
do you have on you right now i'm like
you do know that your grandfather said
the same thing about credit cards like
that's where history's a [ __ ] son of
a [ __ ] go read the quotes from people
interviewed in newspapers in the 60s
about credit cards oh dude i've got one
better for you want to hear something
crazy listen to this this is a true
story
back in the day when they made the
transition to canvas paintings there
were haters that came out because they
said it's not permanent it's not on the
wall it can be damaged everyone
discounted canvas paintings and thought
they were a cheaper knockoff than having
something done permanent on a wall or a
structure
so how quick is how crazy is that isn't
it great because now what's happening
with nfts
[Music]
today was a good day i enjoyed it you
know typical
12 hours of passion
[Music]
by the way how does it feel for you to
to be an artist now do you think of
yourself as an artist you know i used to
always think of entrepreneurship as art
like i i really think being an
entrepreneur is incredibly artistic the
tough part of being an artistic
entrepreneur is the money part clouds it
and it can look dark but it's such a
pure game of art yeah yeah the
motivation for the person running it if
they're doing it well they almost
certainly don't just care about the
money right like i'm in a weird place
where it's it's outside collateral noise
to the process yeah i'm aware of it i'm
grateful for it it's not like i'm not
demonizing it like i love it for people
for me it's all about freedom which i
don't think is just predicated about
money but of course money is one of the
pillars of freedom depending on how one
looks at the world
i just like being artistic i fell in my
pocket with legal tend to cost me to be
the winner fly out before i can see the
winner no more tv then
call time gang good to see all of you
v friends series one is my alpha pass so
i will continue to build on top of that
in perpetuity series two because i know
we're right in the storm right now so i
want to give you guys as much info as i
can this is why you bought a hangout
hawk series two is very special because
this is how the world's gonna really
know this legendary character
not my drawing series two was always
planned to be very close to series one
the reason i in the discord have been
talking about series three being far out
it's because it's far out like i know a
lot of you do pay attention i alluded to
not having series two early more to make
sure that people like held onto their
series one because i knew that would be
in their best interest but series two
was always in play because i knew to
build out the ip i had to create series
two because the animations and the toys
and the video games and the candies
needed series two it couldn't be built
on series one but series three is not
happening next year i want to inspire
educate or nothing else try to take
risks that can help the beautiful faces
in here because this community in here
this 2700 person group doesn't
understand how early we are i can't
believe how many people feel like
they're competing with other projects
when i see moon birds go bananas i have
friends reach out to me and say hey are
you upset about moon birds it took so
much liquidity out of the market for the
series two like first of all kevin rose
is not only someone i admire he's
actually one of my truest dear friends a
b
even if i didn't know him from adam
no nobody's winnings come out of my
winnings and we're all just starting we
need to build each other up and so
let's just talk some facts right now
people are talking about community in
this space but they're not acting that
way
i let them think what they wanted cause
[ __ ] i got bundles of bread and they
bothering
[Music]
headed to wine library the original
stomping grounds for wine shopping spree
woodchuck right it's going off from
memory uh but i'm excited about it so
we're gonna go do that i was gonna say
something i'm gonna wait till you get
there because i wanna see if we do it
okay
that's funny i can't wait to see what
that's about tell me when
hello everybody and welcome to wine
library tv my dad is a piece of work
this is a classic sasha special russian
sardines sam what's the strategy of
russian sardines in the most prime spot
i can't fight i'm over there that just
feel like overkill
[Laughter]
so that was what you were saying it
happened it's still a real passion of
mine i'm such a retailer shining so hard
to go see me in there no more tv dinners
all that i know is i know what i know
and i gotta go learn what i don't i've
been the middle of the night got a new
riddle to write that's the life of an
artist
2009 most influential people in jersey i
made noise right away
think about that like think about like
in 09
like winning that honor but like most
people didn't even know who i was until
five years ago and that's like [ __ ]
13 years ago you know what i mean it
takes time people don't get it i really
do believe when you say you're just
getting started 100
basically that 2009 most influential
people in new jersey is how i feel about
myself right now
no matter what everybody thinks but you
don't get it
i like coming here
it's cool right it is history it's
definitely my history
[Music]
just now we're talking yesterday we went
to wine library for the wine shopping
spree which getting the store is so
different than when i was there but
there was a plaque hanging still outside
one of the offices of me being 2009 new
jersey's 101 most influential people and
it was kind of i just kind of reacted to
the way dustin reacted i'm like yeah man
it takes time like 2009 i get that
little like micro local acknowledgement
that's 100 000 years ago and like nobody
on earth knew who i was in 2009 in the
scheme of things and it's kind of like
what i'm really spending time on with
myself is it's obviously a very
different scale today but god willing
like it's going to be very different in
10 years and so like it's just trying to
like continue to be able to absorb it
because it gets different every time
it's definitely at a real level now
where it's like changed the way my life
is on a day-to-day basis and then just
trying to anticipate what that is ten
years from now and then also
trying to navigate maybe it won't be as
aggressive it's already happened my
content as garyvee
is quite down from a year ago because so
much is going into developing the
characters
i believe that emotional intelligence
has now become the only variable in
business success that everything else is
a commodity that i can find a million
people that know how to work in an excel
sheet and manage inventory but i think i
can find 400 billion people that
understand how to run costs on product
like that everything has become
commoditized in a global economy
except the ability to understand
humanity
[Music]
so we're on the boat
i'm gonna do some fishing another uh
experience in the uh v friends series
one access tokens timing is deep in the
series two launch right now
see how it goes
plenty of things i can go with this
morning but most of all i'm just gonna
go with gratitude what an incredible
fuel
for everything remember in my childhood
i would just be grateful every day that
my parents didn't die i was so scared of
my parents dying when i was a kid and so
life was so simple i didn't have [ __ ]
but i'm just happy my parents were
around and i think simplicity is such a
superpower
and i think gratitude and simplicity in
a relationship are profound right now as
you're watching this video this morning
you're worried about something at work
or something with a neighbor or
something financial and it's really
small in the scheme of actual life it's
definitely not something you're going to
care about when you're 88 so on this
friday morning the simplicity of being
grateful for the simple
is the chat
are you relatively good bishop i'm one
of the best of all time
it's a big [ __ ] fish oh
look at it
wow
[Music]
thank you sir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is an enormous topic of
conversation luck you know anybody who
succeeds there's incredible pushback you
got lucky and a lot of people struggle
with it and by the way me and my youth
as well because the sheer amount of work
it actually takes actual work ethic
execution for someone to succeed in our
society it's incredibly difficult for
that person to
accept when people throw luck at them
because they know the truth of their
work ethic however as somebody who's
worked very hard eight human beings in
russia in 1970 decided an outlandish
plan to get out of the soviet union by
hijacking a plane and acting like they
were going to a wedding got caught by
the kgb luckily golda meir in israel and
franco and spain decide to care about
this singular event and creates enough
pressure on the ussr that hasn't blinked
at that point in 52 years
to let brezhnev say you know what let's
let out a couple of jews appease the
world and we can continue on our path
and i get to be one of those people
you have to be able to accept both sides
of the coin
[Music]
everybody this is uh the end of this
episode and the end of weekly d the team
and i have decided it's just okay and so
we're gonna adjust and we'll go back to
dailyvee we like the context the speed
the output it won't be it'll be dailyvee
because it's a day in the life it won't
be dailyvee from what you knew before
where it was every day always just not
the reality of our world these days but
please leave some comments and let us
know about your excitement of dailyvee
coming back your thoughts on weeklyv
your thoughts on this episode and we'll
see you soon
[Music]
you